good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast we made it through the
quarren weekend it is Monday it is so
rainy and gross in New York really
giving off the ominous vibe that I think
we're all feeling on day nine of
quarantine or whatever it is the weather
is how we feel and also I'm glad that
it's nasty out because I just can't
watch another beautiful day pass me by
where I'm not drinking Sancerre alfresco
it's so true like when it's really
really nice out and I take vo out for a
walk like on a normal day like I will go
around the block one more time just like
for the health of my dog and like my
nose like to get some fresh air but
we're having to be quarantined when it's
so so nice that when you know like this
is the day that you would go to the park
think you would be at the pool at so
house but still like freezing your ass
off because it's an ambitious move yeah
happy nonetheless or like requesting a
seat outside at Gemma like yeah and
crazy things no no so what it's really
really gross out or super cold like
yesterday was freezing according to Ben
who walks the Oh yesterday it makes it
so much easier exactly step outside it
was cold yesterday yeah so this weekend
was the first weekend that I actually
didn't step outside because usually I
have to walk Theo but I have been
paralyzed in my bed with right with a
broken back and then did every single
walk this weekend because I actually
couldn't even get out of bed to wipe my
own ass let alone to walk the dog that
is so crazy that you threw your back out
have you ever no but I woke up this
morning because I did a workout
yesterday and yes you guys I have
cracked in so many different ways on so
many different times like yesterday I
was cracky Oh like I actually thought I
was just gonna like punch through my
window and start to fly like I I've
cracked not only did I work out in my in
my room jumping around my living room
which I said I would never do but I also
ordered a peloton Wow which I think it's
the biggest crack of them all except
once I ordered it or once I had the idea
to order it I was like why didn't I do
this sooner I think my biggest regret of
life is that I didn't have a peloton at
the start of quarantine I feel like I am
the target demo for a peloton I love to
spin I like to make my own schedule I
like to do workout by myself the good
news is that you have so much time to
continue to use it like it's only been a
week well the great news is that a spot
opened up for delivery I guess someone
must have
so their delivery I was supposed to get
it in two weeks and instead I'm getting
it today Wow today I've never been so
excited for anything in my life because
I really think that this is the thing
that's gonna get me through because
yesterday I was like I don't know how
I'm gonna get through I'm losing my mind
well I wish that I could say I was doing
something like super interactive you
know to you know a living room pilates
when I pulled my back out but no I am
bent down in a weird way and I just
never got up I like I started screaming
in pain like I've never screamed so hard
and Ben came running in I think he must
have thought someone had jumped into the
apartment to murder me because that's
what the scream sound like and I just
like it was it's so hard well I honestly
can't go into it I'm still in so much
pain but I'm so much better and I would
love a muscle relaxer if someone is a
doctor who could just call it in to my
local Duane Reade Ben will go pick it up
I need a muscle relaxer like I've never
needed one more
oh yeah if someone's a doctrine is just
calling in prescriptions there's a few
things I can eat so if you could just
reach out I'm having a hard time
sleeping maybe an ambien I'm feeling a
little stressed maybe a xanax I guess
that we just really get me and you know
we're not being able to take generic
brand we'll take out a van okay yeah
we'll take whatever we can get um but
that's one thing people forgot to stock
up on drugs I was saying also on my
award-winning live stream I don't know
if you've been tuning in but Andy
Grammer joined over the weekend he's
saying everyone an uplifting song yep
oh yeah he joined last week I talked
about that and he said I was like he
can't sing keep your head up again oh no
no then it wasn't him I did one Saturday
Kelsey we are joined it was just like
they're they're breaking oh and I had a
physical therapist come on and help me
oh and then Mark Sanchez came up why dad
I saw he was commenting there's a
verified person named Mark Sanchez I'm
like how many verified Mark Sanchez's
are there there was only one and it was
the quarterback well the former
quarterback for the Jets who Nell is a
nice life in Orange County and has a
podcast and wants to come on ours
oh my god we would love to have you mark
um mr. Sanchez if Andy Grammer does come
back on could I put in a request of
course on that song don't give up I'm
not giving up I'm not giving up giving
up no not yet
even though I'm close to giving up my
zipper is a nice little cowbell even and
I'm down to my last breath know
yesterday I was so close to giving up
like I was just screaming I want to go
to the Caribbean and then I started to
work out and I watched some girl on
YouTube and I
stick with her I want him just dancing
around okay like running in place with
my arms like any tic TOCs is a workout
to work out but I just was dancing I did
I think was like a version of aerobics
and just dancing to see a retro and I
woke up this morning I was sore so I did
I did something right okay I'm coming
right that's great I woke up sore but
again for totally different reasons I'll
iterate and move once all weekend well
the good news is that if there was ever
a time to pull your back out and be
immobile it's now and they would be on a
Saturday morning when I still have to
work Monday like everyone's like you
have nothing to do I'm like no I
actually have a very important interview
Monday afternoon like I can't just be
lollygagging around my apartment all day
right and that's the thing the thing is
we have a very important interview
Monday afternoon something we've been
working on for a few days now that we
are so excited that we could be finally
share we are honored to share honored
I'm feeling so proud that we were asked
to participate because we have a member
of the White House coronavirus task
force dr. deborah birx
joining us later today to answer a lot
of questions and concerns that you guys
are feeling or curious about and we are
just gonna talk to her about the
situation at hand
so we're pre recording today so you'll
get a tomorrow's episode on the podcast
and in video form she's actually not
gonna be here with us again because that
would be against the quarantine vibe and
she's in DC doing important paperwork
and important press conferences yeah but
um you guys asked a bunch of really good
questions if you still have questions
there's still time if you go to our
Instagram just comment on the picture of
her um because I don't want to waste
time like I know she's busy I'm just
gonna be like Debra we have so many
questions like no time all again can I
just rattle off like a million questions
she's gonna be like get Claudia you're
beautiful I would say you're beautiful
Deb right I love your scarf yeah and
then you would say like what's your
favorite brand of scarves and she would
probably say they're amazed because
she's like so like so refined I think
you would be like let's fold scarves yes
and then Heather Mooney would walk in
like with her Creek burning cigarette
yeah of course which made her a lot of
money but not as money not as much money
as sandy no of course not no anyways
we're really excited about that so
everything just sort of pales in
comparison but we'll try and get through
the show even though we're like so
[ __ ] stoked to do an icon a medical
icon it's like we're so used to talking
to doctor for Chapman that you would
think that we're prepared for this but
like I do feel a little out of our depth
I mean Theo didn't come today because he
was definitely feeling like a little
territorial when it comes to the medical
field like he's our go-to expert but we
have an actual human go-to expert wait
did you watch curb last night
no what he realized was all great have
someone's watching Mike on
this doesn't spoil anything but we're
getting a second medical opinion are we
yeah yeah I'm really upset that kerb is
planning on ending after this season
because I was really looking forward to
like the whole season of quarantine
Larry or some sort of social commentary
on the coronavirus Zak said that last
night was the season finale so does that
mean it was the series finale
it was pretty final I just say the only
place I've heard that Larry David is
ending career enthusiasms from Ben so I
should have prefaced that but it might
not be true again who also told me that
peloton wasn't delivering bikes he was
half right they weren't delivering
treadmills he was wholly wrong we're
also gonna recap everything we watched
this weekend in addition to our toast
assignment over the weekend which was
the Netflix original series self-made I
don't feel listening on the podcast but
can you hear the rain it's crazy it's
monstrous fall down and wake my dreams
let it wash away let the rain fall down
I'm coming clean wait for it uh Khalif
or us the world turned quite a bit over
the weekend we do have some stories that
are not coronavirus related but of
course we have some that are coronavirus
related because we are living in a
pandemic a historic one yeah but the
celebrities are starting to you know dip
their toe in the pool of you know normal
shoes and I'm grateful for it I really
am because um it gives us something to
talk about I'm grateful for you know
that I am ok so I guess without further
ado yeah I mean you'll never will never
know and you'll never truly know in
these current of times it's never known
whether or not it's time so I'm just
gonna go ahead and say that it's corona
time to deliver the fast 5 stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and I'm just gonna get right into it
because today's sponsor couldn't be more
pertinent because it genuinely saved my
life yesterday
sometimes self-care is as simple as
taking a few moments for yourself to
soothe your body and mind one of our
favorite ways to do that is with the CBD
products from cope re now I threw my
back out and I was talking about her Oh
like I was being so annoying on
Instagram I got so many messages someone
was like if you have a CBD cream it
really really helps I'm like you know
what I do I have the co party won and
I've never used it on my back and it
definitely helped like I was doing a lot
of things to help but I think the CBD
product from co-op re was one of the
things that was most effective on their
CVT products they have a recovery bomb a
deodorant and body comm cream which is
what I used their products only use the
full spectrum CBD power sorry
Co parties products use the only
full-spectrum CBD powder on the market
even better they combined it with their
famous organic coconut oil for maximum
absorption it's one of the most
effective ways to deliver the soothing
and calming benefits of CBD co parries
is dedicated to clean sustainable and
quality sourcing with their whole plant
CBD as they are but they're all of their
products if you're gonna try a CBD
product you should do it right go with
the best go with Co party right now you
can get 15% off all CBD products when
you go to cope re beauty.com slash toast
that's cope re KO PA RI beauty.com slash
toast for 15% off your order cope re
beauty.com slash toast sign on and get
your back up back in shape get back in
shape I never realized how much I use my
back you know I took it for granted like
you use your back probably don't know -
laughs to go to the bathroom to sneeze
to stretch to watch TV to yawn like you
use your back for everything you do and
I never knew it never do it took my back
for granted yeah mom we're praying for
you know that we are i for pillows
behind me right now you have no idea I'm
like I'm literally like we could have
birdies and being propped up okay are
you ready for our first story yeah
because over the weekend a lot more
celebrities have let us know that they
have tested positive for Crone virus
okay
some of our faves including Andy Cohen
travesty Felton under one less of a
travesty because he's young but still a
travesty Debi Mazar a genuine not a
national crisis yes I totally agree I
mean I didn't Andy I was planning on
doing radio Andy from home and they was
gonna they were gonna do a watch repins
live from home and now all of that has
been cancelled which just sucks for us
and I'm really sad you know Andy's 51
that's not like the age that it should
be worried about but he's not a young
sprout anymore you know and also even
young people like Colton are having
symptoms and it's not an easy siren no
am I
to have and I think it's really painful
and so I'm just like I'm so sad that
that he's dealing with this yeah it's
just so interesting how celebrities are
getting tested you know like it's
nothing right and so that's what I
realized and I didn't realize it before
that any celebrity that either has
tested positive or negative for
coronavirus and is sharing it with the
class it's like you skipped the line to
get that test and and Arielle Charnas is
out here like taking the brunt of it oh
by the way justice for Arielle Charnas
because what she did what's like a
little [ __ ] up but like every single
celebrity and celebrities who were
coming out and saying I tested negative
shut the [ __ ] up like you shouldn't you
shouldn't have gotten a test in the
first place right now you're telling us
it was a waste shut your [ __ ] mouth
shut your [ __ ] mouth
okay right justice I agree I agree and
he said and I was hard on her last week
oh you're writing the celebrities no cuz
I just didn't realize that anyone who's
gotten tested who isn't showing symptoms
or as young or as negative I had the
same amount of privilege yep as her and
used their connections to get that test
I totally agree right so also a
celebrity tour saying I wasn't feeling
symptoms but I got tested
why do bite you to test it then why why
why have you back another person who
tested positive which I literally
predicted last week was a jurist Elba's
wife who was sitting next to him in the
video of course I mean she was under
sitting right there being like I don't
have current a virus but my husband does
so right and also like a Zack got
coronavirus you have to stay in the
house we have to stay in the house but
also I wouldn't ever get tested I would
just assume that I have it Yeah right
that's the thing I was like why must
another test and I feel like I should've
some of my friends are having like a
similar experience we're friends of
theirs who they've been with um or
getting tested because they're having
symptoms and so my friends aren't gonna
get tested they're like if they have it
then we know that we have it yeah that's
that I found out that someone I was with
on March 5th had a just recently tested
positive for it so I come in kind of
freaking out about that but I feel fine
and I said to Ben Ben doesn't really
understand like the rules like I'm just
like telling him what's going on and I'm
like bending I have like a little tickle
in my throat and he was like I'm leaving
and I'm like no you don't understand
like if I have it like you have to say
and like just get it if you have it he
already has it like you guys have
smooched you use the same surface a big
time
big seek time smooch you know so we did
a little more than that I'm not gonna
lie
um so yeah yeah I mean it's just weird
when you um are like not I'm not even
personally affected by it but it seems
like a myth until like someone you know
has it yeah so now I even the celebrity
like I don't really know them now I know
personally like a few people who have it
and it's like damn yeah I know three
people who have it now it's it is crazy
and then it just like community wise
right we are all affected and I read
that China had three days where there
were no new cases but they broke that
streak with 46 in cases yesterday oh
yeah so it was good but now it's not
there's over three hundred thousand
cases worldwide yeah I read an NBC news
article and 13 thousand people have died
which is so crazy and 500 people have
died in the u.s. so far and now that the
US has become an epicenter where it's
China Italy and now us I mean that's so
embarrassing yeah um but also who has
tested positive is Harvey Weinstein from
crap just want to say like I'm the one
hand it's like oh my god like justice
has been served on the other hand how
did he get a test on the other third
hand that I have um remember that
conspiracy theory yeah I know I thought
the same thing when I heard the news my
first thought was okay so yes Harvey
Weinstein is like rich and famous but
he's not even rich anymore he's in
prison and he's a felon like how the
[ __ ] did he get a test when there's like
old people with pre-existing conditions
who still can't get tests um he's an old
person and I think also in prison right
now um at least 38 inmates have tested
positive and so I'm sure they're trying
to understand like the situation yeah
what do you do
yeah that's why other countries are
releasing inmates right and it's like do
you value the life of an inmate less
than the life of a citizen and this
really reminds me of a movie I watched
over the weekend called Batman and I
know it's not revolutionary but I just
saw it for the first time when one with
them the one with Heath Ledger because
Ben was like you have been has been
begging me to watch and I said no and
then on Saturday night I said you could
choose what we watched because he
literally was like my nurse the whole
day and I was really grateful
so he said Batman I could roll my eyes
and so I said I'll only watch the Heath
Ledger one and it actually ended up to
Arkham Knight Rises Rises no Dark Knight
oh well also I don't want to spoil
anything in your comedy special oh yeah
but now it's no longer true no longer no
longer false so I watch it and Christian
I was a hottie and I was loving how rich
he was like I really didn't mind the
movie it wasn't very superhero he was
more like an episode of Blue Bloods but
the whole thing is that there's two
boats and both of them have a bomb and
it's like to blow up the bomb with the
with all the prisoners or with the
civilians and it's the same kind of
quandary I guess we're living in now you
know is the life of a prisoner less
valuable than the life of a civilian and
no it's not yeah
disgrace movie mogul Harvey Weinstein
assess it positive for the corona virus
in prison and most likely contracted the
disease at Rikers Island an official
briefed on the matter told the post on
Sunday look I'm obviously mad that this
is another case for America but I'm just
like not mad about the pain Harvey
wanted to he's gonna be in I'm it's not
even as a pain for him like I'm
genuinely concerned that he's gonna get
out of prison because of this oh my god
you know because he could contaminate
other people who is old you know they
are releasing inmates as we let house
arrest
I'm concerned that justice might not be
service is justice but this could be the
opposite of just imagine of his virus
was a whole Everett scheme just to get
Harvey Weinstein out of prison right and
like crazier things have happened
because Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill
himself
no and Khloe Kardashian like was
sentenced to a month in prison and
literally went for a day and she was
like let out to overcrowding so it's
celebrities are always getting special
treatment when it comes to prison they
are but I feel like Harvey Weinstein is
a different kind of animal
yeah he no longer is has access to those
types of privileges but I just feel like
two weeks ago there was nothing that
could have convinced me that Harvey
Weinstein one of the escaped justice and
now I'm concerned
ya know now there has found like a
loophole yeah there's a an ounce of
doubt yeah so and I hate that I do I
hate that no I don't think you're
realizing like he might just be able to
go home no no I totally understand that
he probably will be on house arrest
if this does allow him to get out yeah
where is he currently um Rikers New York
um yes but he was briefly in Rikers
before being transferred to wend on
Wednesday where's went like who's in
charge like you know it says a lot like
Cuomo I don't know if Cuomo would let
him out when was a leader Cuomo's gonna
run for president after this and he's
going
it's a warden thing mmm that's that's a
good point but like come on I've been
seeing things about Kamala Harris she's
in charge of it in California she's very
Pro the releasing of inmates so I think
it just depends like the jurisdiction
the legislation you know who's in charge
yeah
but also if he stays in prison he could
in fact a lot more people right
we don't want that either no I know and
this probably sucks like I'm you're in
prison you definitely kind of visitors
for like the next six months
how boring yeah that sucks sucks okay
next story it's the big story of the day
of the weekend
a lot of people are saying that justice
for Taylor Swift has finally been served
us now that they're famous phone call
video leaked on line so we also the SAPS
from kim kardashian four years ago where
taylor and Kanye spoke about the song
famous and now a thirty minute video has
leaked online
I watched six minutes of it the
highlights that me to her account posted
where Kanye tells her about the line
that the sex has done him in the same
line it says Swift might owe me sex
right but then he also says I also had
this line me and Taylor might still have
sex but he preferred oh me and Kim
preferred o me sex but he still wasn't
sure and she said go with whatever line
you want I loved Kim's input right um
it's funny that the line that Kim didn't
like was the one that made it though
yeah and so people are saying that this
is justice for Taylor because all along
she's been saying that she did not
consent mission for him calling her that
[ __ ] and in the phone call we don't see
him asked permission to call her that
[ __ ] yeah we'll get into the semantics
cuz I'm sure you and I disagree on the
whole thing Feenie sweaty I just want to
apologize in advance I love you guys so
much but guys just ignore her it's time
I'm more concerned about the leak like I
think that this is so fascinating
because the person who recorded the
video was Kanye like his team their camp
so it's been in their position
possession for four years like who the
[ __ ] leaked it now everyone's saying
like Kim leaked it because keeping with
the Kardashian premieres next week and
they wanted more press and they always
love to say that yeah and I don't think
that she would because first of all
nobody really wants to keep going over
this on and on again like literally
nobody nobody so I don't know who leaked
it I don't believe that Kim's camp
leaked it I'm sure there was like a
ditch oh for sure there was a snitch I
don't think Kim's cam leaked it because
people are saying that this proves that
Taylor was right but all along this is
exactly like to me this is no new
information when Kim shared those snaps
it was only ever that one line and then
Taylor's
statement back said I never consented to
being called that [ __ ] but we had heard
the
call and she was in on the song and
bah-bah-bah and it was it was semantics
and like she hadn't heard that line we
all knew she hadn't heard that line yeah
I think that that she had but she was in
on the song okay but the editing was
really really like strategic in the
sense that it made it seem like she was
really really AM on the song and then
everything I said from this thirty
minute phone call like Taylor was so
uncomfortable like she really wasn't
obviously into it she he wanted to
release it on her Twitter like wanted to
use her for her followers which like I
just love that like even Kanye West's
thirsty like I could totally respect
like it's the thirstiest person alive
I respect the hustle um I just think
that it was really strategically edited
to make it seem like she was so on board
and then you watch the whole thing and
like she's visibly uncomfortable
she's taking huge pauses before she
answers him she's like oh like it was a
really awkward conversation and that
just didn't come through the editing was
very strategic here's the thing it's the
exact same conversation that we heard
four years ago but now it's hindsight in
perspective when we heard it four years
ago and she just come off the Grammy say
slamming the whole song and everything
about it and then you hear the video and
it's like oh she knew about this but
she's slamming it and now for four years
she's been saying she did not consent to
being called that [ __ ] and then we you
hear it again with the perspective of
four years where she had said that she
and you see the documentary and she said
that she was just uncomfortable and she
wanted me to like her and now you see it
you you're hearing it from Matt but the
only valid point you just made was that
when she went to the Grammys she said
there's gonna people who trot
they're going to be people who try to
take credit for your success and that
was a line that she approved so that is
a fair statement but again I just think
the editing was was sheisty because the
edited phone call and then the 30 minute
phone call were completely different
like what I got from the edited phone
call was that Taylor knew about it she
was so excited to be like in on
something with Kanye like yeah and the
30 minute phone call it was like he was
asking her to do something that she
really didn't wanna do and she was
visibly uncomfortable and like he was
just not even addressing it oh I didn't
get that at least I'm in six minutes
that the chi-lites said I watch and then
I read some of the transcript it's
pretty much it's the same thing that
came in posted oh no no there's no new
information and we owe and she has new
information always said that she did not
consent to being called that [ __ ] and
we had never seen Kanye run that line by
her and it was always those two stories
right and you by the way I mean you
could believe both if people aren't
saying this is new information people
are just saying that Taylor was telling
the truth I think that she was telling
the truth I don't think Kim
we're talking the truth where it's like
you're gonna go and act like you never
heard the song before when Konya had a
30 minute phone call with you you know I
think that Kim and Kanye were we're
telling the truth but it was like
they're edited narrative of the truth
right and this is her edited narrative
but you see the video he didn't run it
by her no but then you have to go back
to where what she was having us believe
four years ago and Kim and Kanye were
just like oh my god she's gonna pretend
like she had you to know about about any
of this like we're so frustrated we're
tired of always looking like the
villains here's what really happened I
know but in the oh you're getting a vibe
that he is the villain like it was a so
uncomfortable here's what really
happened and that is like and oh and at
the time you're like oh my god she
didn't know and that's all we focused on
but like what she's always said yes is
that it was about that bit did she say
before the edited snapchats came out did
she ever say that she didn't know about
it or she just made it seem that way she
made it seem that way and the famous
thing if anyone takes credit and she is
totally like turnt I don't know that's
not enough for me like she if she never
said that she didn't know about the song
then how can we assume that she said it
you know what I mean um it was like it
was a vibe for sure it was about and she
was just like being the victim and I
think Kim and Kanye were just like
seriously I don't know that video like
honestly that 30 minute phone call like
was it enough to just like literally and
by the way I've always said like when it
comes to this this is you're across
demand-side cross Tamara because I am
the biggest fan of both of these people
and I said like in my soul if I really
had to guess it was probably that Taylor
like was just like kind of playing the
victim but then you watch that that
phone call and it's like no no it was
just it was like I just wish he never
called her like it was the most awful
conversation she you could tell she just
wanted to like be cool and like she was
like hesitating a lot and really
probably wasn't happy with what was
happening and she was literally like
he's like I'm gonna run this lyric by
she's like oh no I'm so scared like it
was just so visibly uncomfortable like
you can't listen to the whole
conversation and get the vibe that she
was so into it but of course you listen
to the end of the snapchat version it's
like oh she was so into it when that's
just not how he'll transpire listen to
the snapchat version now it's the exact
same thing as what we're hearing now but
it's just with perspect eighths you know
it yes it's the context no no it's it's
so differently because the two the two
vibes of the two videos are so
completely different because the Kim one
she got like the last line of Taylor's
saying oh and then everyone's gonna
think I'm in on it
and it made it seem like she was like
really like a calculated monster but
then you the other version it's just so
human like I don't know how you could
think of the two as having the same
message I agree there was no new
information that came out of it but he
got so much more contact it's humane
context is important in the context of
the last four years but at the time when
she you have to remember where she was
she just won the Grammy you know she's
shake it off she's model squad and she's
saying that she's the victim and then
you hear this phone call and it's like
but because model Squad shake it off
doesn't mean that she just wasn't
genuinely uncomfortable during the phone
call no but you hear it through the lens
of all of that and you think oh she's
like you just hear it differently
based on her saying in Miss Americana
like I was you know I just want to kinda
anything at school I want everyone to
like me the fact that she worked so hard
after the VMAs did all of that did that
1981 Grammys just to prove herself when
I when she was doing all that I and I
never imagined it had anything to do
with the way she felt about Kanye and
wanting to prove herself okay but so now
knowing everything we know over the last
four years everything that she's you
know been through reputation etc and
then here are you saying that I only am
gathering that she's uncomfortable
because of the context of the last four
years
okay I disagree I think that any person
you don't have anything about Taylor
Swift or Kanye West you could listen to
that phone call and be like oh this girl
is uncomfortable like she's being put in
a position but she's 104 years ago
wasn't even matter of what was being
said on the phone call it was that the
fact that there was a phone call and
that she did approve a lyric about her
and we can get into the semantics of
that [ __ ] not that big s those four
years ago was just about the fact that
there was a phone call and she was going
around pretending like she was so
offended it was so hard but is that true
for me for you like so you just got
divided but she never actually said she
didn't know about it did she uh like no
because no one was asking her if she
knew about it so I just think like to
say that she was pretending like she
didn't know about it when was she or
rush you know did she ever say she
didn't know about it nobody no one was
wondering whether or not she knew about
it is what how she felt about it and the
way she was feeling about it made it
seem like she you know was so taken
aback the way she was feeling about us
because she got 50% of the story 50% of
the line right but she but when she was
going around she never said he asked me
about this line but he didn't ask me
about that line but I'm saying did she
go around and talk to people like when
before the edited snapchat came out like
people were saying like Taylor Swift is
it doesn't know about it why were people
saying that did she say that
no not doesn't know about it because no
one expected that she would know about
it but he was like Taylor's I'm just so
hurt by this and I just think like
everyone's mad at her like playing the
victim when she didn't even do anything
that was just like a narrative of people
on Twitter and people in the media uh to
me it's is that Grammy speech that she
made her winner at the Grammys about
that song and it turns out that she was
in on some piece of that song and that's
it
and I think at the end of the day we
agree because what she was so offended
by it turns out is the lyric that [ __ ]
and she did not consent to that lyric
yeah so what she has always said is true
yep she was never lying and for Kim and
Kanye was like their truth as well yeah
I just think they're true there's a
Bachelor my yeah her truth Archer I just
think by the I agree with what you just
said I just think that Kim and Kanye's
truth was slightly edited like and of
course you can't put a 30 minute video
on snapchat I just think that they
definitely like you know left
important pieces on the cutting room
floor of contacts that make that give
more background to the conversation like
it wasn't just a 10 second phone call
hey I'm gonna write this lyric oh yeah
let's do it by look no it was 30 minutes
where it took some coercing like she was
visibly uncomfortable she wasn't super
down and he left how to half the
conversation like I just think that I
have the the song there I think that
that's worth noting I do yeah and that's
what she always had said yeah and Kim's
videos portrayed that as well we all
knew it was a very we always move as a
lyric and also it wasn't even the lyric
that wound up making it in I know so
it's like this whole conversation said
um yeah no but it was always just like
just the fact that she was called and
she was acting like a girl who wasn't
called okay but she wasn't acting like
anything because she didn't actually do
or say anything that was just a vibe the
narrative created on Twitter by her fans
and by the media so she didn't actually
have for sure it's all these media's
fault that's quarter I love a story of
course if I could just blame a third
party here the no Twitter hashtag is
over canceled party yeah like totally
that totally it is yes we never needed a
Taylor Swift is over party no I just I I
very much would like to be excluded from
this narrative one in which I never has
to be a part of [ __ ] I literally it's
like the one thing in pop culture that
like no one can agree on and especially
for you and I and especially within our
own self
yeah within my even self I struggle yeah
so I just whoever leaked this like I'm
the one
happy for Taylor that like she feels
justified but on the other hand why are
you doing this we have enough going on
right now and it's like literally nobody
meets us right now just please
especially since there was no new
information okay
yeah but at least we have a story for
the day we appreciate that yeah okay
next up some happy news brought to you
by sin bird I love happy news brought to
you by Sanford have you ever gotten up
to someone and said and you smell
amazing what perfume me wearing scent is
the most powerful since you have a smell
can bring on a flood of memories
influence your mood and of course
enhanced or natural style with tempered
you can have great taste and mix up your
fragrance routine without breaking the
bank
whether it's Tom Ford Gucci or Versace
Sandberg calm keeps you smelling good
month after month excuse me oh my god I
can't breathe so Sandberg is a monthly
freight luxury fragrance subscription
service for perfumes and colognes they
more than 600 designer brands for you to
choose from each month if you choose the
perfume you want to try I personally
tried both a Gucci and a Mao and goats
one that I really enjoy you choose the
one you want to try they'll send you a
30-day supply if you're not sure what
what type of sale you're looking for you
can sort and find your new fragrance by
brand style occasion season and more
plus they now carry other products from
categories like skincare wellness and
makeup they carry cope re glam glow glow
recipe tart and more so we've mixed
loose have offered just for our
listeners and it has recently changed so
if you are wanting to restock ons on
tempered restart your prescription check
out our exclusive offer you can get 30%
off your first month today that's only
ten dollars for your first fragrance go
to scent bird comm slash Steen and use
the promo code Steen for 30% off your
first month that's scent bird SC EMT
bird dot-com / Steen ste and to sign up
and use our promo codes steam to get
your first perfume or cologne for just
$10
sign on smell amazing
okay ready for some happy news sure
Meghan McCain is expecting her first
child after suffering a miscarriage and
will be isolating during coronavirus we
want to say to me before I continue the
story
oh no that's like the main message is
okay I just like it's just so weird to
me obviously this is great news it's
just so weird to me that like life goes
on during coronavirus she feels you know
I just feel like everything stops but
you know life is so weird you know it's
so weird she said although this isn't
how I expected to announce my pregnancy
both we and our fam
are excited to share the news with you
all she also said that she'll start
making her view appearances by satellite
and quote joining the millions of
Americans who are self isolating as a
precaution to prevent the spread of
koban 19 I mean this is actually a very
pertinent thing and something that I
plan on asking dr. Burks about because
we got a lot of questions about
pregnancy and a virus one like you know
how it affects if you even catch it how
it would affect your pregnancy but also
giving birth in a hospital right now
like you can't have visitors come right
and there's no one allowed to be in the
room right so I look forward to asking
dr. Burks about this yeah and she's a
mom I'm sure she's sympathetic yes
exactly but to make it make you happy
for Meghan McKinney to her husband is a
smoke show when I saw her post I was
like so happy no I know it's because we
haven't had any good news in a while
maybe she's also just like a precious
gem and watch what happens live Queen
that's what it is it's like I just
relate to her on a brothel level but I'm
Joy Behar was out but now she's coming
back she's coming back like for hot
topics today like I think they'll take a
day by doing satellite I don't know but
but I think probably from satellite she
shouldn't be going into the studio it's
like at what point do we just like let
it go you know when it comes to the view
like of course that show without you
meant no no I just mean like how I felt
yes there's five people and it's like
now one of those pregnant one of them is
old one I can't come like I what point
do we just like put the view on hold
temporarily even though like it really
is such a pertinent when people are
really lying on it for information um at
what point is it like too much you know
just like got everyone go home we'll be
back in a few months or I mean I wonder
why they continue to film in studio but
like other shows aren't maybe because
there's so many different talents that
they can yeah like e news you know what
have they been doing I don't think it's
been on I tried to watch it last week
and it wasn't recorded um but I mean if
the view like wanted some millennial
viewpoints they could always call us we
are available via satellite we're
available in the studio look we're
addressed I'm wearing a blazer
I'm on I'm wearing a turtleneck okay
yeah cold shoulder cold bucking shoulder
I'm actually quite chilly with this
little opening on my shoulder I'm
freezing because it's cold outside and
the weather outside affects the weather
inside yo and I'm really cold and I'm
wearing a sweater under this whatever
it's better than being hot guys it's
better than being hot that's true well
we're really happy for Megan McCain
wishing her you know good health
and happiness this is great
this is great I'm really happy and I
just love unexpected news you know yeah
it's so unexpected that's that's the
thing about unexpected news and part of
the reason why I really enjoy it is
because there's just a level of like
unexpectedness you know it's just it's
just it's it's not predictable you know
and that's my favorite part
okay next up youtuber Emma Chamberlain
buys a snazzy new modern homeless shoe
myself
Emma Chamberlain is buying the former
home of mat med men cannabis kingpin and
remodeling oh that's so interesting
yes I see when I'm in LA I see those med
men billboards everywhere it's like a
medical marijuana distributor train
chain yeah I guess he's doing really
well because he just bought a new house
for 11 million dollars oh so he gave up
his 4 million dollar house dammit
Chamberlain's yeah he just gave it to
her like for formal as a gift yeah I
just can't believe that Emma Chamberlain
is spending 4 million dollars on a house
and of course I need to look into the
backend the financials here because how
does that match Chamberlain make money
she is a big youtuber which a big
YouTube channel can make you like 20
million dollars a year maybe a little
less she has that Coffee Company which I
don't think is necessarily raking it in
I feel like it might do well she's the
face of Louie Vuitton and that
definitely will she's a digital face a
digital partner at Louis Vuitton never
know if I would say face um she's not
the Fox no but that definitely makes her
cool
maybe million a year I don't know this
is just crazy
and when youtubers like have so much
money coming in and they buy a four
million dollar house do they get a
mortgage I think no I think especially
for youtubers they even Chrissy Teigen
said no wait
yeah they paid like 20 percent down and
they got a mortgage yeah yeah well I've
rent so I don't know the logistics of
being a youtuber where the house but I
am a youtuber and I'm might buy a house
one day so I just want to know what my
fellow co-workers I don't know just buy
it outright I don't think anybody just
buys it outright especially if she just
bought it now you're straight at
mortgages interest rates are super low
yeah that's what Chrissy Teigen said on
her rich people Q&A she's do another one
of those they still do mortgages they
don't just buy a house outright I think
that's smart yeah okay well this is
crazy I mean like I'm a tree Merlin is
so small what does she need such a big
house for you know but I was looking at
the pictures and like there's so much
space for like tich talking and like
making cool content yeah
also um I love her tick tock I think I
was like a like a dancer she's an
excellent dancer and she just hangs out
with her friends and she always reminds
me of Margo I enjoy her tick-tock as
well
yeah and she like makes it her own you
know cuz she's like in on the trends but
it's obviously not totally her realm
yeah yeah I love that for her
the-the-the the form of self-expression
is really it's um pertinent for Emma
Chamberlin unexpected it's unexpected
but you know what is sad about this is
that um due to the toasters
investigatory skills they found out that
Emma Chamberlain currently lives in the
same apartment building as the skinny
confidential it's like maybe you know
her apartment is gonna become available
and then like they could turn it into a
duplex you know yeah oh my god how did
they figure that I have the same
fixtures on the stairs like they're so
insane
but the FBI work and I double-checked it
was definitely true Wow yeah that's cool
yeah and we need to live in that
apartment complex it's obviously we're
successful people
yeah because Emma's apartment already
looks like nice and spacious yeah she
the stairs in it yeah yeah only I'm
really like I'm not a jealous person
oh I like people's homes especially in
these quarren times are making me so
jealous especially like those in
mansions on a hill in the fireplace and
a pool like and now seeing this house
for Emma Chamberlin like I wonder if
she's gonna move in very soon in
quarantine I feel like no I mean
honestly this quarantine it's taken a
lot from me but it's also now making me
hate my own home like I just I think
it's so ugly and there's so much dirt
and all I do is clean and I'm literally
a nanny full-time like been Laurie walks
around and I pick up the dirt underneath
his feet I just I've started to hate my
house and obviously I couldn't have my
housekeeper come and that would have
helped but you know I'm late horn every
day I'm using all my lifes all whites
you know how hard is to clean with a
broken back oh no like do you know
hardest to like lean down to the washing
machine and put your [ __ ] sheets in
that is rough oh my god it's
debilitating you guys how often are you
changing your sheets in the quarren
times well so it's a great question yeah
so would usually I change my sheets
every Wednesday when my housekeeper
comes so to Wednesdays ago I got my
sheets change and then last Wednesday my
housekeeper too income and then so today
I threw them in the wash because I was
just laying in them lesson and they
didn't feel right so I think that makes
it like 10 or 11 days week and a half
okay
that's not bad but I knew if I didn't
change him today I would have never
changed them like I just I I can clean I
just can not change my sheets it's my
least favorite thing to do
least I could change sheets I can't put
the duvet cover back on where I toggle
and I will scrub toilets I will scrub
the floor i dishes i will do the laundry
I will fold the laundry but I will not
wrestle with that duvet cover no I won't
either and then like when your sheets
get out of the trailer they're so
wrinkly and I'm just like not in the
mood like I really hate doing my sheets
like I don't even want to go home after
this after today at work because I know
I'm just gonna take my sheets out of the
dryer because man is useless you she
just like text him and ask him and say
like if you know I ever loved me
no I please put the sheets on the bed
you know right and like I see that every
day like before I have them like that if
you even want to be my wife my husband
like please take the trash out like you
said it's okay too much okay but you
need to come up with something bigger
than well no I've been really relying on
my back and I think I'm definitely gonna
make it because I would say I'm 40%
better
um and I'm really gonna mail get this
whole week like I'm just not in the mood
to walk feet oh and I'm just not in the
mood to do anything so I'm really gonna
milk the back thing yeah but you should
really do it for the sheets like I'm
just really really I'm going to look
after this episode ends I'm gonna text
fan like I'm gonna be home in an hour
like please please please like I will do
anything like you want to be married for
20 more years please just put the
[ __ ] sheets on or you could like
promise him something that he that's
important to him like okay you know
watch Batman - I'm sure you could think
of oh yeah exactly yeah
even though I Loki I don't want to tell
him I hope he's not watching even though
he never watches so I don't even know I
would say that I kind of liked Batman
like Christian Bale is so hot except oh
my god I forgot to say I had the biggest
problem with Batman and it was that do
you know who like the girl was Oh Maggie
Gyllenhaal can Chang dared they know
he's just like that's like Harvey dead
yeah Jim Bale are fighting Batman yeah
no it's like too much eligible bachelors
in the world like really good guys so he
had some great jobs big apartments and
they want Maggie Gyllenhaal I just don't
think that that's probably world works
I completely agree the movie is flawed
inherently and then spoiler when Batman
goes to save right show buddy ends up
being there for Harvey Dent and Rachel
dies that was the best part of the movie
it's that Maggie Gyllenhaal yeah oh she
dies yeah yeah I'm sorry no I just saw
it a few weeks ago actually oh but I
guess they just didn't register
Harvey Dent was handsome guy walking
around with that half a face so and he
and he was only like a good guy because
he was handsome and he couldn't hack
being - yeah and so it's like so you're
not a good guy yeah I just like be nice
to everyone when you're great-looking
and to be honest I never really
understood like the Christian Bale hype
because I saw him in fighter and it was
deaf
really good and when he's just standing
even as Bruce Wayne and by the way his
name being Bruce made no sense but mr.
rain made a lot more sense when he was
just like standing I definitely odd he
was hot but like I didn't understand
like why he was Batman and then when he
put the thing on his job like just his
chin area which was the only part that
was exposed of his body was so handsome
like I totally understood it to me he
really looks like Scott Disick okay to
me I delivery cannot get him
I cannot separate him from him and the
guy who plays Billy in Entourage the
filmmaker I don't know hilly Billy
entourage yeah he's the filmmaker he's
in like the whole series Billy Walsh
yeah yeah Billy Walsh what who plays him
I know they don't even look like but I
literally confuse them so much it's so
weird
what's that the actor's name would
please Billy Walsh I think it's Reese
they're not famous this guy yeah yeah I
get them so completely your block no I
know
Wow and even when I was watching Batman
I'm like you look nothing like Billy
Walsh but I literally get them so
confused that is the weirdest thing ever
I know a Christian male is really a
chameleon it's crazy
what else has he been in I saw I'm in
The Fighter American hustler oh yeah
American hustle
he also played Dick Cheney ones vice and
that's why they make up was really for
that movie stay like literally in every
movie he looks like a completely
different guy he gains weight loses
weight like he does and I just love
Christian Bale cuz he's not a thirst
monster you know like I don't know whose
girlfriend he's all about the craft yeah
and I respect that and there are so many
actors who pretend like they're all
about the craft and just like gallivant
around San Tropez on yachts but they're
not about the craft christian bale like
doesn't leave his house he just perfects
his art yeah like I would say somebody
also reminds me of Adrien Brody oh for
sure someone who pretends to be all
about the craft and he very well might
be but he continues to step out at a
time when we're supposed to be stepping
in Ben Affleck was gonna act like like
him and add into Armus are living in an
alternate universe where we're not all
under horns do I know like okay just
Jared these two step out here is totally
even in the grocery store
step in I understand that like you guys
had a whole press around like planned
out but like you're just gonna have to
put it on pause and we will still be
here waiting for you open arms all over
I will be there with open arms I will be
there with open arms
good thank you okay okay thank you yeah
that's okay Jackie keeps quoting my
comedy special which I'm really
flattered by but it's like so annoying
for the fans because the fans you know
they're just dying to get their hands on
my comedy especially here they're gonna
know what yes yeah that's beautiful
thank you Miss Miniver my heart I can't
believe like how many people are having
to postpone like their tours their
concerts it's so crazy like not to make
it about me but I'm so loud my tours
over
and I just like couldn't deal with
disappointing fans and like losing out
on money I'm so selfish but the fans to
defend itself and of course like I have
three of them and they're really
important okay you're keeping the fans
safe so like you're doing what's best
for the fan and at the end of the day
that's all my two fans one for me is
what's best just to be safe
yeah and one of them is you so I'm
keeping you safe you're welcome Thank
You Claudia stuff okay oh my god I don't
wanna get uncomfortable when Jackie like
mimics my my set honey that's why it's
second man it's just like how I quote
Lee Lee bond like truly oh that's so
nice thank you so much okay are you
ready for a bit thank you so much came
for my I'm ready are you ready because I
think you're gonna love it
okay Ellen is one of them I love this I
love this yes I did did I what I loved
it yes quote Ellen is one of the meanest
people alive Twitter users are sharing
hilarious most insane real stories about
talk-show host after a comedian offered
to match each one with a $2 food bank
donation I loved this this guy I don't
know him but he's my new favorite
comedian comedian Kevin T Porter started
a Twitter thread and was like sent out a
tweet on Friday urging people this is
the tweet right now we all need a little
kindness you know like the kind Ellen
DeGeneres always talks about she's also
notoriously one of the meanest people
alive respond to this with the most
insane stories you've heard about Ellen
being mean and I'll match everyone with
$2 to the LA Food Bank and then he
followed up he's like they have to be
real yeah and so usually it is Twitter
it's at Kevin T Porter because people
responded with um with their
days and stories that they heard my
favorite one is the girl who served
Ellen at a restaurant
and she had chipped nail polish like not
in the food just like on her nails like
romantic here was chipped
and literally Ellen called the
restaurant that I say and tried to get
the girl fired and almost did because
she was walking around with chipped nail
polish like are you freaking kidding yes
their server you work with your hands
like what are you supposed to do here
are some of the highlights a she has a
quote sensitive nose so everyone must
chew gum from a bull outside her office
before talking to her and if she thinks
you smelled that day you have to go home
and shower be a new staff member was
told quote every day she picked someone
different to really hate it's not your
fault just suck it up for the day and
she'll be mean to someone else the next
day they didn't believe it but it ended
up being entirely true
my friend waited on her and she threw a
plate of salmon in his face because it
wasn't what she ordered oh my friend
wrote for the Ellen show for two years
and told me Ellen didn't greet her once
in fact upon employment staff were told
they weren't allowed to talk to her oh
my god Karen killed Grif was her head
writer for five years until the writers
strike when Karen wouldn't cross the
picket line she was fired and Ellen
never spoke to her again Wow Wow I mean
there have been so many like rumors and
myths about Ellen and I think that it's
so funny because she's really is like
branded as the like the nicest woman in
the world it's just so ironic that like
her TV show ended up being like this
place of like real positivity real
change like she worked for the amazing
organizations and she's always giving
worthy people like money and cars and
it's just so ironic like the person who
like ended up being in the face of that
show also ended up being like behind the
scenes one of the most evil people on
earth and there have been so many rumors
about it and I feel like recently as
like celebrities become more and more
like transparent like one with with
their fans we've really really come to
understand that this isn't just a rumor
like it's definitely true I've heard
just too many people in the industry
both people who like our celebrities and
people who work like with talent they
work for management companies like I've
heard from both sides that she's the
worst and I just I love that yeah and I
didn't see that many news articles about
this but this was in the Daily Mail um
and I just think it's important for
people to like share their stories you
know and I just think it's important
that we all just know do you know what I
mean but yeah I hate it's like we always
say like there are people who go around
like they go to the grocery store
they're putting their things on the
treadmill
ready to check out and they pick up a
star magazine and they really believe
that like all the stuff on the cover
like it's true like Jen and Brad are
back together like they really believe
what people are telling them but like
we're investigative journalists and we
obviously know the truth so there are
people out there who literally turn on
Ellen every day like they would die the
chance to meet her and they don't even
know that she's the devil yeah I almost
don't want them to know it's too sad it
is she's hiding she really does so much
good so maybe the all the good outweighs
the bad
feels like because she's making such a
positive difference in the world that
she can like you know even the scale on
the other side sometimes yeah but how
can a Gibson I mean right how can a
person who like if he was genuine she
wouldn't feel right so maybe it's like
the net like I just don't understand how
you could want to wake up every day and
like give away money to deserving people
like support veterans support the lgbtq+
community like how you could be that
person and also person who throws a
piece of salmon at a waiter yeah I mean
get you a girl who could do both for
sure but I just I need to understand you
know and honestly not that anyone's
asking like don't get me wrong nobody
has asked but I think that if I was ever
asked on that show I would most likely
say now yeah I would just be too nervous
I mean you've hurts even when Kern came
on the show and she says like and you
could even see in the interview you
could see in a lot of interviews
actually every once in a while it just
gets like awkward intense and I think
for Dixon Ramsey right for the people
who are celebrities and they go on like
she has respect for them she's able to
let her friends yeah and they are able
to like handle themselves but I think
when like you know someone who's gone
viral comes on or someone from The
Bachelor she sort of just like is so
condescending and I think she makes that
part of her shtick because she can't
help herself
yeah when it's a sort of a nobody yeah
but she's very condescending and you can
if you watch enough episodes of her show
her enough clips like you can see for
yourself it's not so masked all the time
watch the Mason Ramsey interview like
that for me was the first crack into the
real Ellen like I saw like a little
behind the scene of how rude she was
when he was just saying his biggest
dream is to make enough money from this
to go to college right she was like what
she was so rude
yeah you can't understand his small-town
dreams totally yes oh I definitely wanna
go on Ellen also Ellen's like right-hand
man producer that she's like always
putting on TV like came for me so
[ __ ] hard on Twitter with my whole
cancellation like when he tweeted it he
has so many followers when he tweeted it
like it became a bigger story than it
ever was and we also like went to the
same high school and I know like many
members of his family and his
King brother was my high school hockey
coach and he was a nicest man alive
literally I'm like how can you literally
be from the same person he's like I
didn't even know like why the [ __ ] are
you coming for me so [ __ ] hard yeah
so that's why not that anyone's asking I
can't iterate that you know enough I
will never go true I would support you
thank you
like maybe I don't know we'll see
there's a few things that it's like
would be really prestigious even some
like guests on the show like that we've
talked a lot of [ __ ] about that I if
they want it like if their press person
wanted them to come on like I would say
no oh look big celebrities yeah like
there's some opportunity said it's like
that's just not who I like it just goes
against what I think yeah I mean that's
one like instance Ellen but like even
having someone like actually don't want
to name any names I don't want to say
anything because you know maybe they
want to come on maybe they and maybe
I'll feel differently about them one day
but like someone that I'd like to talk a
lot of [ __ ] about on the shows like they
wanted to come on I would I would say no
like I would be too uncomfortable yeah
and like maybe they come with notes like
on December 1st you said this about me
that is untrue I just wouldn't be able
to answer for my my sins yeah so I agree
with you ok um ok let's get into our
segment where we kept everything we
watch this weekend which for me was a
lot and that segment is brought to you
again by fiber let's talk about finding
freelance talent for your business or
project finding the right freelancer can
be time-consuming frustrating and
expensive where do you go to find the
talent how much will it cost how can you
be certain that they'll deliver thanks
to Fiverr finding the right freelancer
doesn't have to be a struggle their
marketplace helps you get more done with
less Fiverr connects businesses with
freelancers who offer hundreds of
digital services from graphic design
copywriting web program film editing and
more as a small business ourselves we
are constantly looking for freelancers
when it comes to graphic design video
editors different production elements
and I never really knew like where to go
like I was already searching on
Craigslist but fiber is everything that
you needed more you can find what you're
looking for instantly search by service
deadline price reviews and more you'll
know exactly what you're paying for
upfront no negotiation needed
plus they have 24/7 customer service
quality talent you can count on sellers
have worked with some of the most
influential brands in the world finding
talent for your project has never been
easier and you can review seller ratings
by your feedback and select the right
freelancer based on your budget take
five and check out Fiverr today
fiverr.com you will receive 10% off your
first order by using our code toast it's
so easy don't waste any more time to get
the services you deserve by going to
Fiverr fiv eerr comm code toast fiber it
starts here
but wait actually I'm reading some
comments and I take back a little bit of
what I said because if I was true to
that that me never would have had Nick
vile on the show oh that's true and we
never would have started such a
wonderful friendship with him that's
true so maybe sometimes it's good yeah I
guess I'll be case by case
so let's um let's jump into our toast
series of the weekend we assigned
everyone to watch selfmade which was the
Netflix original series on the life
inspired by the life of madam CJ Walker
I don't know it kept saying inspired by
sweat there was making me think that
things that was making me think that
there were certain elements of it that
weren't true oh I didn't think that but
like it was a very like cute picture and
I'm sure they like glaze like glamorized
so I memorized it and you know skipped
over some things or maybe edited like
some Q conversations or whatever like
was it true that she ended up stealing
from Adi Oh probably probably but I
didn't fault her for that at all
no look about that was to work for Adi
but Adi was a [ __ ] and by the way the
success of Madame CJ Walker was
obviously that the product works but it
was more so that like she was marketing
and making people feel beautiful not
just a certain group of people but
everyone yes and Adi never could have
done that even though she had the same
product if if madam CJ Walker never
stole it and never would have become
what madam CJ Walker did because it
wasn't honest it's colour-pop and Kylie
cosmetics yes oh my god in formula but
it's all about how you're selling it and
how you're making me feel that is so
true a lot of a lot of the reviews that
I saw people loved it they weren't like
in love with Tiffany Haddish when I
thought she did a great job but she was
so cute especially if madam CJ Walker's
daughter really was like a free spirit
fun-loving girl like then Tiffany
Haddish was everything of the sort yeah
she was great I thought she was great
too and I loved when she moved to Harlem
like I loved that whole thing I loved
this story I never knew the story before
I know that she was the first female
self-made millionaire a core what yeah
in the u.s. I loved that she ended up
living on the same street as a
Rockefeller like that way everything
that was everything that house had
googled it after like it's so nice
sickening sickening I just I absolutely
it's an amazing story and dr. Robert was
just the worst oh he was the worst but
his dad was the best his whole series I
want to know what happened to him I know
and it really it makes you think we
spoke about this we were just on
Margaret Joseph's podcast last weekend
we were talking all about like what type
of man can be married to a successful
woman and like it really is not
for everyone let's look at dr. Robert
Lee it's like he was not well no one
like he even wasn't automatically bad
like he really tried and he tried to be
supportive but he just like couldn't
take himself out of the equation I know
and he couldn't even see himself as like
maybe being not good at his job like he
was like that that sketch of the girl
like that's just not that was not the
brand yeah and I just don't understand
that because if like my significant
other was just having so much success
and like well how am I gonna go and make
it I'm go to sleep I'm just gonna sit
back and enjoy the fruits maybe start my
own thing
but I Spit on I insist that I get
involved and make it worse yeah I mean
well you think back like back like now
it's okay for like a woman to be on a
personal level yeah I guess all those
dynamics have changed but I'm just
saying like
isn't it just nice to like be with a
successful person and enjoy those fruits
I was just living for Madison
these are out of control first I was so
confused cuz her name was Sarah and I'm
like maybe this isn't about CJ Walker
like I was so confused but then his name
was CJ and I was like okay they never
really explained like why the name of
the company was his name but I think
it's because that when you married
someone like you became mrs. CJ Walker
yeah and probably to be taken seriously
like they thought it should be owned by
a man yeah I thought it was there were
some things about it that I really liked
there was some like scenes are just the
way that they filmed it that I liked
wasn't crazy about yeah um but overall I
loved it it was such a feel-good show
when the scene went um when she got the
Saunders contract I literally had chills
and then at the end like if you didn't
watch it yet but right and time I was
watching the fireworks like with her
pins like her parents and her future
descendants like I literally was gonna
start crying same except I had one major
problem the way that they incorporated
this new adopted daughter you know even
though we never got to know her and that
contact I am sure that in real life like
this girl was a part of the business a
heart of the family like grew up in the
house like I am 100% sure of it but
literally we met this girl in the last
episode and then she ended up being the
heir it's like she was just standing
with Tiffany Haddish and CJ Walker like
it was just she was not supposed to be
there like she was virtually a stranger
according to the storyline like it was
just so convenient that this girl just
showed up and she was beautiful like
crazy that that's actually what happened
it made it feel like fictional yeah but
I'm sure that in real life that this
girl was like a major part of the story
of the family they totally miss
especially because having an heir for
madam CJ Walker was so important to her
and they just sort of kind of threw this
in at the end where it's like that is
everything that girl should have been on
the second episode when they were in the
salon like even if even if that's not
how would happen like she should have
been a part of the business for longer
or a few more scenes where she's just
like having family dinner and she's just
anytime that madam CJ Walker and Tiffany
Haddish are together
she should have been there right after
we met her it took away from the
authenticity like it felt so coming and
extort you know that girl just came the
last day no she was like the authentic
story is that that girl did become a
part of the family her children and
grandchildren are the ones who are
carrying on the legacy right madam CJ
Walker and I'm pretty sure it's that
girl's granddaughter who wrote the book
inspired by this series that inspired
the series yes I'm so glad you agree I
thought that was like so random and just
like an afterthought when it was so
important it was so important and it was
it was not well executed but also just
like makes me so happy that even 100
years later that now like the world
knows that Addie was just like such a
[ __ ] I know I I just want to know like
who was the real Addie oh yeah but it's
like I'm sure at the time she liked
every with every win she was like I won
yes like no 100 years later and you have
very much lost and the whole what I
gathered from the entire series is that
men are [ __ ] like when [ __ ] Tiffany
Haddish she's husband was going addy and
then like [ __ ] some Adam CJ Walker's
husband was like tricking on her and
like I just I was getting so frustrated
and I was continually being led down by
these idiotic men and I was just I was
getting so frustrated I'm like look
they're literally babysitting these men
like making them a living making them a
home making them everything cooking
cleaning and being the breadwinner and
they're still running around cheating
spying and then it's not enough like
I've literally was getting so frustrated
Tiffany Haddish is husband was like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] here's the moral of the
story men are [ __ ] except for W EBD boys
yeah his dad right know that he's like
the icon he was in Harlem with them he
was the one that you when when she got
the when she was having dinner and then
when she fainted and Ramson ransom
ransom he was everything he was
everything when he gave her that $500 in
the end to the beat I was so upset and
then that scene where he ended up
getting lynched oh my god that was
[ __ ] terrible and he was like I grew
up my whole life being embarrassed of my
cousin and he was he got killed for my
son oh my god I wanted
I was so sad it was so sad to me that
look I think the mark of a good show or
movie is something that makes you laugh
and makes you cry yeah because Octavia
Spencer was being hilarious like she was
just so unstoppable like she was really
making me get oh yeah and but also it
totally made me cry gave me chills and
that's just what you want out of your
Netflix series and I really haven't seen
that much promotion about it maybe
because of the corona times it's been
sort of overshadowed well you know
Netflix has done their top ten it's
number one oh good because I think it's
such an important story I think it's
very fabulous story I'm like embarrassed
that I didn't know it no me too and I
also want some of that magical hair
grower like so I don't know if the
Walker company is still in business
because I googled the Walker company and
the first thing that came up was like a
plumbing company in Minnesota Oh
interesting and they said in this series
that they went to business and in the
70s and then they stopped and yeah the
timeline after that so it made me think
that the Walker company went out of
business in the 70s that's okay yeah I
mean 80 years or whatever that's a good
million dollars in like 1920s probably
two zeros okay so it's a hundred million
dollars yeah not too bad
plus you know if you invested wisely
stock market cetera you know it was
really it was just that about add two
zeros yeah that's what I heard once like
when you calculate inflation like back
when America first got started it's two
zeros interesting okay so like at the
piece of pizza used to be like 25 cents
two dollars and 50 cents they said then
he bought like a beer and the show was
25 cents and then I was like add two
zeros two dollars fifty cents for a beer
is like not that crazy 25 cents or $25 -
okay wait point two five yeah add one
zero well move the decimal I don't know
maybe a third pie pizza 25 honestly you
know what a beer these days could cost
$25 yeah yeah it just depends where
you're maybe a piece Pete's used to be a
nickel yeah oh yeah a nickel that would
make more sense no but then it's 0-5 so
you move one watt and then $5 yeah maybe
that was it whatever all in all a great
assignment and I'm real glad that we
chose it when he gave her $500 now that
would have been $50,000 and it's like
damn that's that's that's factored and
that's something that your wife like was
concerned about and that's factory money
yeah so that's what I was thinking I was
thinking add two zeros but
again I just I don't know why I know
that like where I made that spell in
Sephora it's still in business oh my god
get some of that hair grower Oh Douglas
well and then it was so interesting to
see her hair over the course of the like
when she was home and she took her hair
out of the hat and everything her hair
was like down to her ass
it's called Madame CJ Walker beauty
culture Wow amazing okay it is still in
business I'm sorry for spreading this
information yet again here on the show
so we'll recap what else we watch but
we're gonna give a new assignment which
I chose and I wanted to watch last night
with Ben and he was like not in the mood
um but to me I just can't believe I
don't know about this movie it's on
Netflix it's called Mad Money it's a
2008 comedy featuring Diane Keaton Queen
Latifah and Katie Holmes where they like
rob a bank or something they all work
and like at the federal reserve as
janitors and they end up stealing money
so I just couldn't believe there was a
Diane Keaton movie that I didn't know
about that also featured my favorite
Queen Latifah and then also Katie Holmes
but I don't really like died for her
it's on Netflix it's called Mad Money
and I don't know anything about it I
don't know if it's good or bad but I
just thought like we should all see this
movie like I didn't even know about it
yeah sure it's uh Netflix check it out
that's the assignment for tomorrow
another thing that I watched over the
weekend was New York minute which you
told me that was on Netflix yes oh my
god what a treat huh what a treat you
know I I totally forgotten about that
movie and how it was really like their
first grown-up movie like there was just
like nothing it was like sexual or
anything but there was just it was more
mature you know I think they may even
have like a different production company
because it wasn't that like passport to
virus Paris by now and this one was in
theaters yeah so I just really loved and
I I remember this being kind of like
their last movie and it really made me
sad because at that time in their lives
they were like so cute they were
everything I if they had made a few more
movies that movie was actually really
good I was surprised at how not dumb it
was no it was so good and just like new
on star-studded dr. drew their dad Avril
Lavigne scene doctor Avril Lavigne's
teen one said Simple Plan was actually
in it eugen lady was the detective like
it was star-studded it was star-studded
it was really really good oh and the two
guys who played like their boyfriends
were like such classic 90s guys that
guys from Gilmore Girls and then the guy
on the bike that mary-kate ended up with
like he was just like a classic like
rom-com 90s teen star marry Mary Kate
ended up with the senator's son no
opposites attract yes Ashley did Ashley
played Roxane no yes I played Roxy
Ashley did I looked it up man
can't played Roxy okay eye candy York
minute
New York minute cast Mary I'm Tony
Ashley played Mary Kate played Roxy
Ashley played Roxy okay we're gonna find
out in three two oh [ __ ] okay okay
played Roxy yeah whatever yeah like that
guy was from Gilmore Girls and then the
other day I was like so um classic like
he was he might as well have been in
like what a girl wants like you know
yeah no it was the casting was on point
it was so cute and it's a great like
actually they did a really good job in
the city except there were a few times
when they were like traveling up and
down downtown they were like on Park
Avenue then they were in Midtown and
then there were Flatiron I was how about
you they did like a pretty good job yeah
the the movie I don't think couldn't be
made today because they were playing
into some really offensive
Chinese stereotypes but I was able to
look past it but I just wanted to be
noted like things have changed so much
you know like you could never really
make a movie like that things have
changed the other thing I watched all
day yesterday was the tiger King and
everyone's talking about it I came at it
so what is it I didn't watch it it's a
documentary about this I didn't even
know what it was about until the end and
to be honest this whole trend of
documentaries being made into TV shows
where they have seven or eight episodes
to me is still unnecessary Tiger King at
seven or eight episodes and it was
really really funny in the beginning and
like an interesting story but by Episode
four I was done but then was enjoying it
so I watched it I guess I just wanted to
see how it all ended up it was basically
like battle of the Xu's like there were
these three or four zoos all across the
country a couple years ago that were
competing for like the same business and
they were all breeding exotic animals
and it's actually not illegal to breed
exotic Tigers and have them as pets and
it was just it definitely highlighted
like how weird it is that there's no
legislation against having like a tiger
in your house and breeding them and
there's there's no there's only 5,000
like a big cats left in the world and
like literally 100 of them are in
America in random zoos like why so that
I thought the message was important but
it was just so silly like I don't even
know how to explain what it was and to
me everyone was wrong and the guy who
ended up in jail like he was he was
insane but he was virtually harmless and
all the people around him like really
framed him I think but the weird thing
about it is that one of the guys
involved he wasn't the star of the
documentary he was just like an someone
who added context was another zoo owner
his name
da canto listen it's interesting and
when this mean this means ooh guy got
sent to jail he was mad that all the
others you guys didn't go to jail and he
gave them dirt he gave dirt to PETA and
he told PETA that da can tell you thin
eise's all of his tires once they get
past a certain age because they're not
you can't like pet a big tiger with kids
around
he euthanizes them in a gas chamber he's
a gas chamber on his property like he
was giving such crazy things to peed up
and it ended up being true with 2019 the
FBI invaded da Kantos farm but Ben was
like this name sounds so familiar and
Ben follows an instagram account called
Cody antal who ends up being da cantle
son and who like runs the Safari still
he's like all these celebrities Beyonce
went that way the Kardashians went no
they went to black Jaguar white tiger in
Mexico and that's an actual sanctuary
for animals like this is a zoo and
beyonce has been there logan paul like i
was just looking at this guy's instagram
he's like a huge star he has two million
followers his dad is obviously not the
face of the company anymore
since this documentary came out i think
that's the best decision he has the gas
chamber is a gas chamber and was rated
by the FBI and it turns out his whole
thing was a cult like literally all the
girls who work for him they have to live
in the property they can't stop working
like it was a cult like and it's just
like you're and you're like you're just
being an influencer and like taking
videos with all your Tigers he posted
one last night and all the comments no
one was even mentioning I'm like you
related to da cantle he used the nicest
Tigers wow it's such a dumb documentary
honestly I was annoyed that I wasted
seven hours of my life on it but what
are you gonna do well I'm glad that you
did so that I don't have to yeah but
there were funny things like Joe exotic
he was this guy he wanted to be a star
Jackie like he had his zoo it was all
about him he sold merch with his face on
it he started making music videos he he
had a web show like he wanted to be a
star he had a he hired he was making a
lot of money at one point
hired like this world-renowned producer
to come down and film his whole life to
pitch a reality show the tiger King Joe
exotic like he was so insane and to me
he was interesting and he was like the
focal point of the whole documentary but
he was the one who ended up in jail for
pretending to kill this PETA activist
like it was so stupid honestly I can't
even explain I was it was really dumb
but I watched it because everyone's
watching it and that's what I do these
days and that's what happens when people
aren't putting out premium content and I
don't understand where what the what the
point what's new I don't understand
where the content is like yeah every
other day of life there's always
something exciting coming out and like
we're home for two weeks right now and
you can't give us a throw some
bone here he's into of the society where
the [ __ ] is season two of the society
where's know me now drop the rest of
little fires everywhere now oh I started
the book little fires everywhere and I
love the premise and like it's just I
agree so suffered like so my vibe but in
the book I think I'm at 20 percent it's
just a lot of backstory so far oh that's
funny cuz in the series we've gotten no
backstory oh but no you're probably
watching the backstory like as it plays
out whereas for us this is all in
hindsight I don't know it'll be
interesting I actually because I'm so
[ __ ] does it start with the fire yes
oh and then it goes to how we got to the
fire yeah that's our the show is because
I'm so [ __ ] bored like I want to have
the experience of reading a book seeing
how I feel about it and then seeing how
they make it into a show because that
sounds like a new sensation that may get
me through these quarantine you know my
last year in college I took a class
called cinema and lit where you read the
book and then watch a movie and I didn't
read any of the books but I enjoyed a
lot of the movies yeah so I think
that'll be like a fun thing to do on
Friday
I read American Royals which was the
book that snitch and I were meeting
together and it was super cute she loved
it way more than I did I gave it a 4 but
she gave it a 5 but I would recommend it
if you're into just like cute why a
rom-com hallmark even richer then on
Saturday I watched self-made and I
started little fires everywhere I've
also been watching the bolt type like
throughout I'm on a season 3 now um and
I like hate like it you know there are
some things about it that I really like
something's out of that I there's no
there's direly little content like you
just have to stick with the dumb shows
right and like the things that you know
and it's cute enough and I'm also in the
middle of little fires everywhere still
i watch curb boss is such a good it was
one of those perfect
I'm gonna watch when I get angry like
you know how he just like everything
starts there like a circle it's perfect
okay and I think it felt like a season
finale okay I'm hoping that it's not
also that got one of those latte Larry's
hats because you know how many happy did
the club and I asked of her shirt but
they had already sold out and I just
really want a latte Larry shirt I know
one works happy if anyone works a man
happy I really want the sweatshirt with
Larry's face on the back I think we
might have to go to ebay pay a premium
though okay well anything for latte
Larry's and honestly his coffee looks so
good no it honestly lucky Larry's looks
like an oasis yeah no it literally it's
everything do I just have a so but it's
everything I would ever want like clean
tables bolted to the ground delicious
hot coffee scones that oh no I like
scones head herself I think I would like
mocha Joe I don't like scones I mean I
would eat one I think you would like
mocha Joe scones because their muffins
right okay we have to go because we are
gonna prep for our interview with dr.
deborah birx which is going to air on
tomorrow's episodes if you listen to
tomorrow as a podcast it'll be at the
end of the podcast and if you're
watching as a video it'll be available
as a video separately from tomorrow's
episode right after we and the show so
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium Morning
Show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe to
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and we're podcast
can be found so that's Spotify I should
stitcher public radio I our videocast
box all the places whoever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast thank
you hi leave a five star view about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are stay
at your house we'll be alone together
and we'll see you tomorrow yeah your
house will be alone together - thank you
to all the health care workers who are
saving lives